the idea of this program is that it's a
Japanese talk-show that then is
overtaken it's it's invaded by an alien
who eats the host of the show I think
and then takes over the show is that
right it's a giant talking blue alien
from another planet that took over a
Japanese morning show and killed half
the staff ate them and then enslave the
rest have his own show the gore burger
show which you know which is a show that
he's completely surrounded by Japanese
people he's interviewing indie rock
artists and pop culture icons and it is
the strangest thing I've ever been a
part of my parents really like it and
that doesn't make any sense there's like
that's quite inventive I'm like okay
buddy
how did this concept come about it's not
I've heard a lot of iconic you know
pitches for television shows I've never
heard anything quite like that how did
you get this idea well so the director
brothers Josh Martin and Ryan McNeely in
this case Shawn McCoy are John Boyle
sorry he's gonna be so upset that I
mispronounced his name yeah
they sort of approached me about this
and gave me that pitch and I was like
yeah of course I'll do that same as
Paris alien toucan when I hear something
like that I'm like yes that it yes yes
right and you know I was I was excited
about I said how did you come up with
the name and so this ties into gun Film
Festival al gore was at this party at
gun and and and so these guys the
director brothers they were out really
really late one night and probably
perhaps smoking marijuana and they they
were talking about Al Gore and their
favorite hamburgers the best kind of
hamburgers and they combined the two
Gore burger burger so ice
yeah so I saw Al Gore you see the actual
alcohol a actual Gore so I say I'm gonna
go over to him and tell him the story
this is amazing I have this puppet of
this incredible show he's the reason
that it's named Gore Berg
I'm gonna go over and I'm gonna tell him
just that but I was very wasted and so I
so skated so he went over there and I
said mr. gore I just so I'll show it's a
giant
it's Japanese and thank you for
everything you've done for the
environment my wife Kate's just like
okay we're leaving now thank you out
honestly thank you for everything you've
done for the environment but it's it's a
show that is unlike any other and that's
the kind of stuff I like to do that's
excuse me all right it's the
slide-whistling it yeah it is well we're
gonna buckle e on the mucinex man so I
get free we're gonna meet we're gonna
meet the gore burger yes coming on the
show for burger alien is coming on the
show today we're actually going to meet
him that's exciting
[Applause]
you